as has been the pattern you might have
noticed with a lot of stuff intriguing
and in verse 3 we're going to look at
the case of sign spend some time
developing that and then you can pretty
much work out cause and tear on your own
steam okay so let's consider this and
what I'm after is its derivative okay
now just like before we said was it a
four unit lesson you know things we know
about integration we get from
differentiation right well a lot of the
conclusions we're drawing about inverse
trig you get from regulatory right so
how can i rephrase this in terms of
regular trick so that then I can work
with it because i know you heaps of
stuff about regulatory right well we've
learned that if this is the inverse
right i should be able to say that x
equals sine Y for certain values of Y
which ones in what cases are these two
equivalent because they're not always
right we have a restriction what kind we
have a range restriction do you notice
why at this point it's kind of not very
useful to us to mention the domain
restriction anyone see why what's the
domain restriction on this we just
talked about this it's negative one to
one is it it's I of this right but then
again this is always related with one
the whole you don't sneak that goes up
and down right if you say but X is
between negative 1 and 1 you haven't
really restricted it at all right this
is the important part okay so so long as
I keep this in mind which by the way is
critical right we talked about nuances
before which we usually just sort of
skirt over you cannot afford to do that
anymore we're gonna this is going to
become critical to argue later on in
this range we can say these two are
equivalent in that range and only that
range all right now we want a derivative
don't we you can differentiate this
right what is different derivative
be it's not in terms of X is it it's in
terms of Y so it stands you I RDX I will
get DX on you i like so differentiate
with respect to Y ok don't get confuse
their just labels right I can call them
whatever I like so the derivative of
sine of course is guys ok that's good
that's progress I have a derivative now
but I don't have the derivative that I'm
hunt right I want d y ou D X so this is
a fraction right I can take the
reciprocal
movie magic okay that's nice that's good
is that what I wanted I kind of I want
to do ideas I've got an expression video
ideas the only problem is it's a bit
weird because it's in terms of why mmm
it's a bit weird isn't it okay so how
can i rephrase it in terms of what I
know X to be because I won't do one of
the x equals blah blah blah some
function of X ok here's a thing right we
have we have this relationship already
built in this is cousin this is sign so
how can I relate cause of science again
I could do this but that's not going to
particularly help me here because it
won't get rid of my why right so what
else could I do what other kinds of
options do I have I could think of
Pythagoras good night I can think of my
failures the Pythagorean I know you here
don't forget I mean wise right tells me
that sine squared y plus cos squared Y
is equal to 1 happy with that okay now I
want to get rid of a causeway and
replace it with a sailor I can do that
that's not that hard cos squared kick
the other guy over to this side now what
will my next line be take care here
what's the next line going to be
I want cause so you would take the
square root of one side what are you
going to end up with on this hmm I'm at
least going to get that because I've
taken the square root for left hand side
so I better take the right hand side but
I'm missing something why are we missing
plus or minus missing apostle my toes
now let's stop here for a second I could
argue this another way okay but I think
we have enough information on the board
for you to say no this is actually not
true cause why is not plus or minus the
square root of one minus sine squared
but why not we're looking at this and
we're saying look cause why there are
two alternatives to mutually exclusive
alternatives for what its equal to ok
now it's equal to one of them and only
one but the question is which one ok so
you're suggesting you're suggesting it's
the positive 1 1 now I'm happy to accept
that but you need to give me a reason
so I did give you a big clue before
didn't I right I said you noted down a
range restriction and I said it would be
critical right so think about how this
makes a difference on this right there
are Y values here so therefore cause why
can't just be anything what is causeway
look like in this domain sorry this
range actually no I am thinking of
domain now because I'm going to graph y
on this axis and I'm going to graph
close Y on this axis okay what's it look
like in that to me well the whole graph
looks like this but which section of
that are you interested in just that
middle section aren't you negative piled
soon up to play on to hey go and I'm
going to include those boundaries that's
ok cuz they're 0 their problem ok so you
can say this equals this because but
cause y is greater than or equal to 0 in
the values of Y that I'm interested in
causeway is rather than week 20 when I
apply this restriction ok so now you're
saying to get hangar the fact that
restrictions make all the difference
here right you can't just say it's the
positive one because i want the positive
one okay you need to provide some
rationale all right great i'm going to
bring that over here now 1 over the
square root R one minus sine squared Y
happy with that and of course i know it
sideways it's at so i have an answer
that uh
that's the derivative sign of us it's a
little bit unusual isn't it mmm you
differentiate trig functions and you get
trig functions back and we're used to
that you differentiate inverse trig
functions and what you get looks nothing
like anniversary function that's
interesting now I said to you before
that this was not the only way to argue
this right and get one answer at the end
let's just have an experiment suppose I
did not draw this conclusion I was just
I got to hear another room okay let's
just see what happens okay how did that
change what happens on the left hand
side if I carry this possum itís with me
I will get too young and then I'll get
to here and then I would scratch my head
right we're not used to differentiating
things and getting out to derivatives
because that's two derivatives isn't it
right why am I getting two derivatives
like is it did I do something wrong for
what reason would i get two degrees now
think about this the reason i will get
two derivatives is because i have not
accounted for this restriction right it
was accounting for the restriction that
limited me to one of the two that make
sense okay I tell me what does this
thing look like without restrictions I
think it looks like this let's see you
crazy okay so this is the middle part
and then the rest of it having not
restricted it looks like this okay now
look at it with the restriction which
part are we interested in we're
interested in from here to here what can
you tell me about the grid gray is the
derivative in that section it's um well
it's always positive except for where is
it not positive
at the at the end points right at the
end points the dream is not positive
because the derivative doesn't exist
there right because when you stick in
negative 1 or 1 what happens you divide
by 0 of course you do because you've got
a vertical okay you get it so therefore
in this little section it's always
positive but if you don't restrict if
for instance you're looking up here
that's not positive that's negative and
it's exactly the negative like it's plus
or minus its the negative of what you
would have if you looked at one of these
areas you see they're exactly opposite
to each other right so that's why you
differentiate something it looks simple
why do we get two derivatives out
because you have language for this this
sucker is a relation of course he has
two derivatives maybe if it was a really
weird looking relation we'd get more
right but it just so happens that you've
only got two possible things you could
be that the increasing version or the
DPC version depending on where you are
that makes it